bath is with us
Beth is in Colorado hi Beth how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up Bible son who is a
senior in high school going to an
unknown college next year when his
father and I divorced seven years ago it
was written into our divorce decree that
we would split his college expenses
50/50 and unfortunately I have been
unemployed for five months and so I'm a
little bit concerned about how to stay
out of as much debt as possible if I
don't find a new job by the time he goes
to college and the reason I'm kind of so
concerned about it is because I've been
applying for jobs for this whole
five-month period and I've not received
even a bite on an application so I
realize this is kind of a what-if
scenario but I do want to be prepared if
my employment situation doesn't change
well your employment situation has to
change because you have to eat this
college situation or divorce decree
aside how are you eating for five months
well I am unemployed I'm getting
unemployment right now that will end in
June and that's enough to live on well
no I am remarried as well however my new
husband and I we share expenses as far
as you know bills and the mortgage and
utilities all of that kind of thing but
none of our finances as far as our
children is we don't have any together
we've got we both have kids from our
previous marriages none of our finances
regarding them are our joint because you
know we've both got very different
situations but he's also been divorced
from his first wife for seven years but
she continues to take him back to court
constantly and so we just have never
merged every single part of our finances
so I can't really expect what does he
make a bigger man I want to say
probably about 55 um if you don't
legally merge your finances you need to
emotionally relationally merge them for
the good of your marriage and you don't
even know what your husband makes that's
not okay you guys have got to pull this
out you use know there's this an excuse
to keep this separate and and to keep
separate lives acting like you've got a
roommate here and that's a problem it's
gonna it's going to cause problems for
you so you do whatever you want to do
I'm not gonna tell you to borrow money
to do this and so that leaves you with a
couple of options one is to as you said
you've been diligently hunting you'll
continue to do that I'm sure you'll lend
something but if I were your husband I
would help you with this until your
finances change because of this and so I
don't think that's out of line I
understand you have an agreement with
your roommate to keep things separate
but I don't agree with it I don't mind
your and you don't agree with me and
that's okay you're gonna do whatever you
want but you called and asked me so you
end up getting me so that's how that
works but the deal is that if I were
your husband I would want to have more
of an integrated life with you even if
legally we separated the stuff because
of the constant child support hassles
and because of the technicalities of you
know raising two kids and all this kind
of thing and there aren't neither one of
them yours I get that part that part's
okay but you guys really need to be up
in each other's business a whole lot
more than you are and have combined
decision making have combined futures
and combined future goals and combined
pain and combined carrying the weight of
the household and it's not like well I
can't carry my half right now so I guess
I'm gonna get evicted it's not no and I
can't do what I'm supposed to do for my
son right now so I wouldn't I'm not
gonna tell you to go borrow to do this
and I would either make it up with
income and or if I were your husband I
would be willing to step in until you
get your employment situation
straightened around
and help you with this process for
better for worse for richer for poorer
sickness and in health
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
this is the old Book of Common Prayer
marriage vows and so that's how I lived
my life I understand if you don't want
to do that I'm not mad at you about it I
just think you're wrong hey thanks for
the call